like i remember i remember i thought
like when i first walked into the store
when i was doing like my most expensive
figure challenge i thought the most
expensive figures was gonna going to be
around 200
because that's what i could find at
first um so knowing that that's 200 i
think uh yeah what's your most expensive
figure
we'll get to that oh my god he's [ __ ]
teasing us as always of course of course
true youtube needs a clickbait right
uh so this is the second figure that i
bought uh so this is
this is from one of my favorite artists
yum
yeah
so if you didn't know yamu did uh miru
tights and he has done the art for
another anime that's coming out this
season i believe which is uh ganbare
probably shouldn't have that on the
screen for too long oh [ __ ]
yeah oh okay
i didn't see anything
maybe since that mood on yeah the back
of course
open it up guys okay well i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep it as static as possible so
mudan has an easy time censoring this we
get it it's it's a it's a very hot
figure um so let's let's see this out so
i didn't actually know that uh his
characters had figures so when i saw
this i've never seen that either
actually yeah because like i don't do
you count this as a hentai figure i
don't really count this as a hentai i
mean yomo is a hentai artist if it's not
from an anime and it's inspired by like
a hentai artist but he has he has made
but he's made an anime mirror tights was
an anime hero ties his anime and i think
his ganbare doki chan yeah i think i
think that's the second one where it
like focuses
on office girl workers yeah um and i
think this is clearly has his uh
fetishes
put straight i respect it what i'm
saying is he has amazing art
stop talking show us the figure i'm
trying to okay this is uh this is going
to be the first of many lude figures uh
because because you had sydney's okay
yeah unfortunately having sydney as a
camera woman um i'd i'd like i'd
sometimes just wander off and then i'd
look behind me and she just wasn't there
and she'd just be like filming this lewd
figure and i'm like sydney
i feel so sorry for allen because he's
got a like
he's got to censor most of this
oh this is nice yeah that's nice that is
very nice and that chair is like nicer
than the figure
holy [ __ ]
this chair is nicer than the one i have
at home
dude i want this sofa look at that put
her on look at that
all right okay i'll give it to you
that's pretty [ __ ] hot yeah that is
like that i like that that's hot oh
that's hot
next to the pikachu is the funniest
thing i've ever seen
but like the duality of man how how lewd
is this
that's not too bad the box the original
art is definitely yeah yeah
well i say like he is a [ __ ] god when
it comes to drawing thighs and uh those
tights it sounds like you're moving like
a stonehenge-esque thing on the tail
when you move that around
honestly this uh yeah all right that's
pretty good it's pretty good it's pretty
good all right nice
i mean obviously i have to represent uh
the greatest anime movie ever made
oh okay we got a canada figure from
akira this i think was the most
expensive thing what was that connor
what was that what was that
well you don't like it no it's fine it's
fine
did you also get
can they care for you
not at all no you sure about that
mood rewind that because i'm pretty sure
i saw conor's life flash before his eyes
when joey took that figure out all right
how would you pay for this
uh this one i paid
uh
20 275 dollars for this one oh yeah i
didn't say how much i paid for the yom
figure figure i paid
um i paid
what is this
a hundred and twenty dollars for this oh
that's not bad which is pretty weird
yeah i had i paid 120 that looks like a
300 figure yeah i know right
damn that's really good i think i i
think i got a good deal
okay i haven't actually seen the inside
of this but uh oh it's one of these
right okay
it's like the old is it like an action
figure yeah it's like an old school
action figure oh okay
one two six yeah i saw it because like
you know i this was at the point where i
had already bought the the joseph one
and the one that can beat goku which
i'll show after and i was you know i was
i was having a good time i was like this
is the start this is the first one i'll
peruse find something cool and i found
this and uh i couldn't not get it
because yeah i love akira because uh i
was going to buy summer hero figures and
then i kind of realized joey's
definitely bought an akira figure not
gonna lie i completely forgot about the
whole like duplicate yeah
uh so i was like you know what
what i i forgot yeah
no because i remember you're the only
person who bought an akira figure last
chance no no no no no that was gone oh
that was connor was it you yeah it was
me okay i just assumed it was joey yeah
where's the yeah there's the canada one
right oh was it you i bought this one oh
okay this is extraordinary it kind of
looks like a kendall doesn't it does
look a little bit like a kid
i got like an akira
that is an akira kendall right there it
looks clean though that does look clean
yeah let me let me know why don't you
yeah all right what is uh what is your
next one connor um well
what is that you just [ __ ] chuck that
on connor i don't really know um so what
do you mean you don't know you bought it
it's native
creators collection
illustrated by
you don't mean to take it though
why does that name sound familiar
well joey because it's a hentai figure
so do you know what it uh looks like
i do
[Laughter]
did you have a look at it no gone
because my challenge
was to open a figure i sorry choose a
figure yeah uh blindfolded oh this is
the oh this is the one this is the one i
chose blindfolded which which aisle did
you go in to like oh clearly he went
into the mailing instructed i think or
maybe we both chose to go in the hentai
one i'm not sure yeah let me know yeah
look look inside of a [ __ ] can i say
can i [ __ ] hell
let me see let me see
[Laughter]
all right turn it turn it around slowly
so moon has an easy time uh censoring
this jesus christ connor
[Laughter]
let's go
if if this is on the line that is that
is definitely over the whole the whole
thing is on show yeah that's uh that's a
full display again i didn't choose to
get this figure can i say that
i need a closer inspection oh [ __ ]
unsensitive looks weird oh so it's under
the desk that looks so weird dude do you
know what's weird about copper do you
know what see do you know what's weird
about seeing hentai figures it comes
with an optional moaning face okay oh
hell yeah it comes with an eye oh let's
go do you know what's weird about
himself figures it's the fact that the
[ __ ] coochie is unsensitive yeah it's
not pixelated as [ __ ] yeah i was like oh
yeah that's what it looks like so how
much detail is there on there way too
much
it's a lot this is this is just you guys
i didn't buy this for you guys
guys give it back to me
yeah wait unless you can take this off
is that is that removable i don't know
well guys it looks really well luckily
it's uh
so close that's a nice angle here
that's what i'm talking about i don't
know what this hand is doing guys what
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry it goes on
the desk
i don't think that's how that works
i don't know if that's how that works
yeah on the picture it's on the day oh
really like this
oh yeah
yeah yeah
sorry
uh if you're on a patreon enjoy if
you're on youtube sorry that this is all
blurred but
i'm wondering what this looks like on
youtube is it is it going to be blurred
or is it just going to be the black box
it's a black box or is it going to be
like the white glowy thing no it's not
done choose carefully
is it the white bars
i'm taking this off now yeah that was
two hundred dollars oh my god you know
so you've spent two two hundred dollars
it's taller than that two two hundred
dollar figures yeah well i had to make
sure i reached the 500 minimum i mean
was that nothing you just wanted to buy
out of like your own volition i was so
focused on the challenges because i had
one that i struggled with which we'll
discuss right next time after money will
span i say
you can take that one home i'll take
that one huh